the fractal woman okay and she made a
little video
uh in which she answered uh one of my
videos
and she answered specifically the issue
about the ether and it's good that she
did because
now we can uh get deeper into her
train of thought see if we can
understand what she's saying i certainly
couldn't
so i'm in the same boat no matter how i
look at it you know she hasn't answered
the question
and so let me show you what she failed
to answer what she
doesn't answer what she can't answer and
she never will obviously
and here it is okay let's go with the
first one she says the following
she said the vacuum of space is not
empty okay
it is just empty of matter but full
of ether okay so she's saying that ether
is not matter whatever matter is and we
saw that you know they don't have a
definition for matter
it turns out she's going to say that the
ether is made
of particle and anti-particle pairs but
she doesn't call that matter for some
reason
even though you know those are
considered you know one of those is the
electron
and the other one's a positron and these
are considered particles and if they're
considered particles what is that isn't
that matter
so we have a problem with the word
matter a serious problem because we
we end up going in circles because of
this word because people say
it's empty of matter and what did you
say by that well she didn't say anything
with that because she doesn't know what
the word matter
means that's why and she said vacuum is
empty of matter again
okay she's empty of matter okay so here
i've got matter down at the bottom and
yellow you see the yellow ball
and i put it within space and you have
the ether there which are the red and
uh uh white or gray balls there right
and so uh that's that's the uh that's
space for her space is that ether
plus the particles of matter whatever
matter is okay
and space is full of ether okay so a
space is full of ether and space is full
of
matter okay so what is the vacuum well
vacuum is the same thing as space but
empty of matter
so that's what i did at the bottom right
i removed the ball the
yellow balls and that should be what
she's saying she's saying look
the guy on the left is space because it
has matter in it
whereas the guy on the right is just
that same thing but without
the yellow balls okay so what is that uh
vacuum
uh that vacuum seems like it's got
something in it what are those little
balls those uh
electron positron pairs that she's got
the vacuum made up of
and uh so she doesn't call that matter
for some reason and again
it comes down to that word matter so she
gets away with murder there why because
she's putting particles and she's saying
that's nothing
that's not matter okay that's that's the
problem uh
at least that's the first problem okay
and we'll continue here
and say space and ether are the same
thing okay so space and ether are the
same thing
and vacuum and space are not the same
thing right because
a vacuum is space that is empty of
matter so
that i did it right i removed the yellow
balls which is which represent matter
and we end up with uh what she calls
vacuum and
as always you know we have problem with
the black stuff we don't know what that
black stuff is and that's what i want to
get to i want to get to that
the bottom of that stuff that's the one
i'm targeting okay
so i want you to understand that and she
says space is filled with light term
positron pairs
so that means she's talking about that
ether those electron positron pairs that
make up
uh the ether right and which i let her
generalize to vortex anti-vortex pairs
okay
she's going to explain how she creates
these these little tornadoes okay
okay so we have electron positron pairs
our space
okay because what electron positron
pairs are
ether and ether is space she says uh but
she says
but she's obviously she keeps missing
when she says that she keeps missing the
part about
matter because uh space and
ether cannot be exactly the same because
ether are the red and white balls
whereas the matter are the
yellow balls and so ether and space are
not the same thing if space
must include matter okay because she
says that
if we remove matter space would not
exist because
uh she would not have distance between
objects and again she doesn't consider
the little
red and white balls there she doesn't
consider that matter she doesn't
consider that anything i don't know what
she considers that to be
especially when she says that they're
electron positron pairs which are
supposedly particles so again we have
this this problem where these people
just keep running around in circles
and she says i call space a vacuum when
they are when there are no particles of
matter in that region
okay great space and ether and space is
in my electron positron pair medium are
the same thing okay so it's very clear
space would not exist if this medium
would not exist there she goes he says
if if the medium wasn't there space
would not exist
okay and again we have a problem because
we need to figure out
if uh space is equal to the ether which
is just the red and ball
and and white balls or
space includes the particles obviously
she means that space includes the
particles therefore space is not the
same thing as the ether as she says
okay so she's got a contradiction there
she's got to resolve because if
if space is the same thing as ether then
it's the same thing as vacuum which is
what we have on the right vacuum is
equal to the ether
and still we have no idea what the black
stuff is as of this as of this moment
she's going to get to that in a minute
and so she says so space is the medium
and vacuum is when there are no
particles in that medium when space is
empty when it's got nothing
in it nothing meaning matter because we
do have something and
those something are the electron
positron pairs isn't that something
i mean what is that so this is the
problem is he keeps
running around in circles she thought
she answered the question she hasn't
okay
and he says if all the matter
disappeared in the universe and all the
vortex anti-vortex
pairs disappeared from the universe
there would be no space yeah so what
would be all we would have is the black
stuff and what is the black stuff
that's what we want to get to so she
hasn't yet addressed that issue okay so
she does address that in the next one so
let's get to the next one
she tells us what the black stuff is and
that's what i wanted to know you know
what is this black stuff
she says because the black stuff
supposedly gives a shape to the
particles that's why i want to know what
the black stuff is
and she said the background for the
particle for the particle is the vortex
anti-vortex c okay so the black stuff
there that you see is the vortex
anti-vortex c okay
and uh a part of the sea of vortex
anti-vortex pairs okay whatever that
means and okay and the background for
that is the bec the bose
einstein uh condensate okay in the bec
right the background of the vortex
anti-vortex pairs is the bec
itself oh i love that one because that
means he's saying
what is the bc well if you look it up
it's it's a gas that's what bc means
okay
bc is just a gas that's a very low
temperature that's all bec means that's
the bose
einstein condensate okay it's just a gas
that's been cooled down to near absolute
zero that's how it is and so they say it
has different properties and they call
it a different state of matter that's
all it is
okay it's just another type of plasma
you can say where plasma
goes to the other end it's heated up uh
you know atoms that are being ionized
well this is another type of uh
uh experiment where you freeze the gas
and you find that it's got different
properties at near zero uh kelvin
okay okay so that's what the bose uh
einstein
incontinence it is that's gas and there
i illustrated
i put different colors and she says that
uh the yellow and um
i'm sorry the green and pink one there
little balls uh those are those are
gonna be
the black stuff the black stuff is made
of all those little balls
and that what she says provides the
contour
to the ether to the uh what is it to the
uh
electron positron pairs so we've got
this gas
that she feels in there and she's that
gas gives the
uh the background to the electron
positron pairs that form the ether
okay so we're getting i guess to the
bottom of things here are we
uh i want to know what the black stuff
now that contours each bec
atom because we're talking about a gas
but i'll assume they're just particles
so what contours each one of those
particles that's what i want to know i
want to always know what the black stuff
is
and she hasn't told me what the black
stuff is and she's telling me the the
black stuff is the bc behind the bc it's
the same contour to the bc she says it
there she says
the background of the vortex anti-vortex
pairs is the bec itself
the universe began as a bose einstein
condensate at a very
super low temperature at absolute zero
or very close to it
you get a bec then as you either spin it
up or warm it up you begin to see the
formation of vortex anti-vortex pairs
so she says that she creates these uh
tornadoes
simply by having the pair run around
each other that's that's
her idea she says you know these two
pairs of balls they go around each other
next
in her mind she says that's an anti a
vortex anti-vortex
pair and then that tornado i'll just
call them tornadoes because that's what
she's
describing those tornadoes form the
background okay
uh uh she says he gets a bc well that's
not totally true because
again uh the bc is not a tornado
according to the official
uh literature the official literature
says it's a
gas and a gas is made out of atoms she
doesn't understand that okay so that's
that's her problem then as you either
spin it up or warm it up you begin to
see the formation of vortex anti-vortex
pairs
so the background of a bc is pure
inertia
now she says that the background is a
concept
she's saying that we have this thing
called inertia which he defines as
resistance to change
so he says the background is resistance
resistance is a concept it's like saying
love is the background or intelligence
is the background
what meaning can it have to say that the
background of a bc
is a concept an abstract concept a
mathematical concept
so again she doesn't make any sense
whatsoever she never has defined what
the black stuff
is she just diluted it with more
nonsense that she included one right
after another saying well this is backed
by this and this is backed by that and
that's backed by something else
and she never tells me what the last
thing is backed by what what
what is the thing that gives shape to
the last particle that gives shape to
all the others that's that's what we
want to know we want to know what the
black stuff is
and as you can see she has not answered
the question she alluded it okay
and so uh the the funny part is she she
gets upset
that uh you know i say she's not a deep
thinker and she's not she's absolutely
not and i'm not
insulting her i'm just being factual
here she's not a deep thinker
and she should not be in physics she
should not give she doesn't have
qualifications to do physics
she should not make a fool of herself in
public
so if anything she should take my advice
okay
that's the way i see it uh anyways uh
here she here's a i try to draw a
picture uh
more specific so that you can see her
train of thought in pictures okay so all
that
she just said i'm gonna put in pictures
so that you get a an idea which she's
got going through her mind
to the best of my understanding okay
she's got a particle
okay and she's going to call that matter
okay we'll call that matter okay
and that's the yellow particle she says
that matter particle
is encapsulated or the background to it
the one that gives its shape
is the ether okay what's the ether it's
these uh electron
positron pairs okay okay that's the
ether so i want to know what the black
stuff is that gives shape to them
and so she says oh that's the bec okay
let's go to the bc what's the bc
bc as we know are gases so she says
there's some kind of gas there
that when heated up turns into a tornado
and it's all these cool tornadoes uh
very low temperatures that form the
background well the tornado is not a
physical object sorry
okay so we can't use the word vortex in
science because it's not a standalone
object
okay and i'll get in in fact maybe i
should show it right now here it is
this is a tornado okay and one on the
left is known as an ice cream cone
the one on the left is an object for the
purposes of physics the one on the right
is not a physical
object you don't you don't have a movie
you don't put to a movie and say that's
a physical object
okay and we've gone through that the
other day and here's another
version of that the guy on the right is
known as a jumping kangaroo that is not
an object for the purposes of physics
the way you present an object for the
purposes of physics
you point and it's got to be static it
doesn't have to move
okay if it's moving it's not an object
and what she says is that
this uh her vortex she's saying the guy
on the right there she says that's a
physical object and that's not a
physical object so she doesn't
understand the
foundations of physics okay and of
course
uh then she says okay so she's got these
uh tornadoes
okay and so i i want to take my
microscope and go and see what those
little particles are so here on the
right i'm seeing it directly i'm saying
look i have in a bec
gas particle and that's the one in the
center and she says
the background to that is also a bc
another another bunch of particles okay
so i put it
in six you know i enclosed it or
encapsulated in six particles there
what's the black stuff what gives shape
to each one of the bec
gas particles that's what we want to
know and she never answers the question
she and she never will
and let me tell you why because since
the days of the greeks
they realized the problem they said you
you know you can't continue to say well
this is
backed by this and that's backed by that
and that's by backed by something else
at some point the bug has to stop you
can't keep putting objects
and saying an object uh serves as
background or contours another object
this is not like you say you know you
put a ball in a box and say well
where's the ball well the ball is in the
box or in an ocean right
you put a fish in an ocean so you say
well what counter is the fish the ocean
well what contours the ocean what's the
air
well what contours the air because the
air you know surrounds the earth
and at some point you got to reach space
and you got to address what space is and
it better not be an object
because this space is an object then you
got to tell me what contoured space
and it's just going to go to infinity
what are you going to say the fourth
dimension is that is that your answer
and then you say what's the fourth
dimension well we don't know what it is
and that's the other that's the fine
print and we're done you know you can't
go beyond that point
and that's the problem with mathematical
physics today you know uh
they don't have an answer to what
encapsulates it all the last thing
the thing that you say encapsulates
everything else i want to know what
encapsulates that
and you can't have an object you have to
at some point say look what
encapsulates everything is nothing what
is nothing that which doesn't have shape
we're done and now we know what nothing
is when something is because they're
opposites
they're antonyms and we can use them
consistently in a dissertation
that's the foundations of rational
physics